today former president Donald Trump
heads to Texas for his first official
rally of the 2024 campaign Cycle City
officials estimate a crowd of 15
thousand will watch Mr Trump take center
stage and solidly red Waco Texas but his
looming indictment is also center stage
and now a federal judge is ordered close
AIDS including Mark Meadows to testify
in a special counsel investigation into
January 6th
Caitlin Huey Burns reports now from
Washington Caitlin good morning good
morning to you Michelle well as all of
those legal challenges intensify so too
has the former president's rhetoric just
yesterday the Manhattan district
attorney investigating Trump received a
death threat and law enforcement
officials have increased security around
New York City's courthouses Trump has
used the threat of a looming indictment
as a Clarion call to his supporters and
amid all of this he's heading to Waco
Texas tonight to hold the first official
rally of his 2024 White House bid
it's dangerous
and if he keeps it up he's going to get
someone killed house Democratic leader
Hakeem Jeffries responding to Trump's
explosive comments on Truth social where
he warned of death and destruction if
he's indicted on Friday Manhattan
district attorney Alvin Bragg received a
letter with a powdery white substance
and a typewritten note saying Alvin I'm
going to kill you the substance was
determined to be non-hazardous Bragg is
leading a grand jury investigation into
Trump's 2016 campaign finances and hush
money payments to adult film star Stormy
Daniels criminal charges against Trump
in this case could be nearing Trump is
facing the possibility of becoming the
first former president in American
history to be indicted and is aiming to
Rally supporters to his defense he'll
hold the first official rally of his
2024 campaign tonight in Waco Texas the
site of the deadly standoff between
federal agents and the brand Davidians
around this time 30 years ago and in
this 2024 bid Trump has focused his ire
on Florida Governor Ron DeSantis who
could launch a campaign of his own later
this year well I would say if you look
at some of the the change from that and
all the way up what's been the kind of
the major thing that happened that's
that's changed his tune was my
re-election Victory the gloves are
starting to come off for DeSantis who
pull show could be Trump's top
competitor for the Republican nomination
I mean I think at the end of the day
what a leader you really want to look to
people like our founding fathers like
what type of character it's not saying
that you don't ever make a mistake in
your personal life I think what type of
character are you bringing
now the Trump campaign said the decision
to hold tonight's rally in Waco was one
of logistics noting that it's centrally
located to the state's biggest
metropolitan areas but Jeff some of his
supporters have noted the parallels to
an event that they see as a symbol of
government overreach
okay Caitlin Huey Burns thank you very
much